voir les minutes qui viennent politique
à presque 18 mois de l'élection
présidentielle Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne
veut plus perdre de temps dès janvier il
souhaite que ses partenaires se mettent
d'accord sur le nom de celui qui
briguera la candidature du Front de
gauche sans complexe 2 ans seulement
après la création de son parti il a
affiché son ambition au man Angel matoxi
Philippe
lagone la Marseillaise le point levé une
nouveauté au Parti de Gauche le message
est clair le Parti de Gauche est bien un
autre parti de gouvernement à gauche le
PS doit faire avec à la tribune Jean-Luc
Mélenchon menace Garau socialiste qui au
prochaine cantonale chercherait à
évincer ses candidats bien placés en
faisant alliance avec les vers je vous
mets en garde solennellement nous ne
laiss-m pas faire ce type de coalition
qui divise la gauche et la meurtrrice
mais chaque fois que nous aurons été
agressés nous vous disons d'avance que
la réponse de ce que nous allons faire
ne vous est pas connu et vous FZ bien
réfléchir à la stratégie l'Union d'abord
l'Union d'abord l'Union d'abord et quand
on demande à ganluc Mélenchon si il
compte se Dister en faveur du PS au
second tour de la présidentielle le PS
devra nous rejoindre si c'est ça votre
question Jean-Luc Mélenchon veut croire
qu'il peut être la première force de
gauche avec son partenaire communiste
mais avec quel candidat Mélenchon ou le
candidat PC chassigne il y a quelques
temps en tout cas Pierre Laurent le
secrétaire national du PCF n'hésitez pas
à critiquer la dérive populiste de son
encombrant allié du Parti communiste
français donc je je suis pas là juste
pour je suis pas un pot de fleur sur une
tribune en tout cas s'il y a des gens
qui pense que le Front de Gauche va se
fracasser sur cette question de la
candidature il se trompe lourdement mais
la d'honneur les militants l'ont réservé
à un autre invité Jean-Vincent plac le
représentant des ver la direction du
Front de Gauche aimerait faire des
écologistes des interlocuteur
privilégiés les militants se sont
divisés sur cette question ambiance
bisutage
devant Jean-Vincent Placé ils entonnent
l'international le vert n'est pas assez
rouge à leurs yeux Jean-Luc Mélanchon
lui a gagné son Paris plus aucun parti
de gauche ne peut désormais prendre le
risque de l'ignorer on revoit